hello everyone and welcome to a most
anticipated game from round five of the
bill chess festival 2018 it's both of
them are doing extremely well in this
tournament is the clash of 2,800 The
Clash of leaders but before we check out
this game we do have a nice photo
challenge it's could be a this could be
the the most difficult photo challenge
yet so best of luck to everyone who is
this supposed to be now of course this
isn't this probably or most likely it's
not what the person actually looked like
but this is used when you know talking
about this person or you know writing
about him on the internet so best of
luck to everyone and now let's check out
some of the photos from this game here
we have a nice photo before the game
even started both of them you know just
shaking hands you can see in the look on
mama dr-dos face that's the look of
someone who has to play against Magnus
Carlsen most likely for for a long long
time with the black pieces and here we
have you know a more joyful photo there
you can see that perspective really does
matter as mamedyarov is you know taking
a different approach to solving the
position so there you have it we're
gonna check out the standings after the
game now let's check it out
efore e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 a move invented by the man
from the photo challenge we have a six
more fees defense Bishop to a four and
the knight to f6 d3 b5 now so all
standard stuff Bishop to b3 and Bishop
to c5 now the Carson goes for a c3 it's
not possible to go for some some sneaky
moves like Knight captures on e5 and
after captures d4 because this is
actually perfectly fine for black after
Queen captures d6 and it's it's actually
black that's more active and stands
better here but okay after Bishop to c5
and the white it didn't really achieve
anything
c3 d6 and now Bishop to g5 we have h6
momager of immediately asks costs and
what are your plans with this bishop
here however we want to retreat it to h4
maybe back to e3 not really something
that you want to do
but also a very interesting line is
Bishop to d5 it's not better than what
Carson played but it's just interesting
maybe if you're in a blazer game maybe
you want to give it a go
but after Bishop d7 captures captures
again it's black hood who would be more
active
so after h6 Carson goes back up to h4 we
have castles Knight bTW - and Bishop to
e6 now offering a trade of bishops while
this is possible for white captures
captures Carson doesn't like giving
blacks at such a nice Center and also a
semi semi open file for his f8 rook so
after Bishop to e6 who have castles
Bishop to b6 in in time the C pawn will
have to be pushed forward rook to e1 and
now Bishop captures on b3 and here I was
sure Carlson will capture with the a
pawn always you want to capture towards
the center capturing what a piece is
better because it doesn't ruin your pawn
structure but I really thought that he
would enjoy this semi open file for the
rook but instead actively Knight
captures on b3 we have nice to be a
preparing to remain over tonight and now
is no noise from b3 is guarding d4 d4
Knight B to d7 we have a 4 now striking
on the queenside
rook to e8 and now comes Queen to c2
Queen to e7
and now h3 simply I useful move rook a
to b 8 and now a capture some b5 a
capture some b5 and Knight to a5 cross
and is threatening Knight to c6 to fork
the Queen and the rook
so my media of accepts the knight
boishakh captures we have rook captures
on a5 and now C 6 and here rope to a7
already a small victory for Carlsen but
against the 2800 player maybe even more
than a small victory as he does have a
look on the seventh ranked Queen to e6
unpinning
and here rock to a1 definitely an idea
but Karsten prefers the rook to d1 we
have nice to affect
rook to seize a rope to c7 and now
Mahmud era of simply counters the rook
eat the c8 and here again a very nice
idea by Carlsen the whole rook lifting
rook captures
and c6 of course it's not a rock
sacrifice or anything
momager of characters and now comes d5
attacking mamuro's queen and rook queen
to see it and now comes pawn captures on
c6 recapturing the pond immediately
would lose you the game after a bunch of
captures and f6g captures and night to
h4 there are simply too many resources
here for white black would not be able
to hold this night a5 is coming with the
threat of e7 night h6 queen is coming to
e2 to g4 and this would very very likely
be unwhole double so after D captors in
c6 we have 90 to e8 and now another nice
move by cross and brush-up to e7 we have
Queen captures on c6 grabbing that extra
pawn and now nice to h4 preparing to
bring the Knight to f5 to create a
triple attack against the d6 pawn we
have Knight to g6 attacking Carlson's
Bishop on e7 but cousin doesn't my
Knight to a5 all the same as now
capturing the bishop would result in
losing the Queen and the game of course
so after Knight to a5 we have worked to
b7 Mahmud Arif finds a very nice way how
to protect his pawn rather he will not
protect it he will just grab another
pawn so better captures Clausen grabs
upon we have route 37 now attacking the
bishop the bishop has to move there's no
weight to add more protection to it we
have Bishop to e3 and now rook captures
anyone now
the Queen has the capture and no longer
will should be protecting d4 pawn queen
capture somebody want and now Queen
captures on e4 with an attack against
cousins f5 knight Knight goes back to e3
and here Knight to f4 is definitely a
nice idea of constantly pressuring that
G to pawn first Mahmoud Arif goes for
Knight to f6 and now cousin plays g3 he
doesn't allow Knight to f4 anymore so
what's what's cousins plan now the
material on the board is completely
equal five points each the difference is
cousin has a knight and the bishop
against two nights but the one thing you
have to notice that cousin has two
points on the Queen side against one and
okay
has an extra ponen the King said but
this is less important as you know you
are far less likely to push the points
in front of your King while there are
pieces on the board so Carson's plan is
definitely push b3 and c4 create a
passed pawn and try to push it as far as
he can so we had H 5 H 4 and Queen to c6
now we have Bishop to b4 protecting the
c3 pawn so B 3 and C 4 is now an idea
and now mama deriv simply has to wait he
plays a waiting move Queen to a8 sorry
about that
first he plays King to h7 we have b3 and
only now Queen to 8 waiting for c4 c4
it is plate B captures on c4 b captures
on c4 and now Queen back to c6 and now
across and plays at Bishop to d6 another
very nice move
preparing to push c5 we have King to g8
and now comes c5 and now again a very
interesting position and nice to e4 or
Queen to e8 again is the is the is the
top choice from the engine but here mama
D are played Queen to e4 and it's it
seems this is the move that Carson did
not take advantage of his position as
much as he could here cross and play the
Queen to f1
but there is one move in the position
which which seems to give a give black a
you know a lot of advantage so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the the epic engine move both of them
missed you know it's an engine move so
if you want to do it you know give
yourself more than a few seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it in
graduations you are able to play the
endgame like an engine and for those of
you just wanna enjoy the show
Bishop to e7 seems to be the idea the
thread of course is Queen to d8 check
followed by capturing on f6 winning upon
and after Knight captures the bishop
then comes Queen here Queen d8 check
King to h7 and Queen captures and now
you see that the queen is still guarding
the c5 pawn but also there is a threat
against the f7 pawn and after the f7
point is guarded King g6 now comes Queen
to d6
with the idea of pushing the past bond
and also pinning the night here so the
night can't move after a couple of
checks queen bee one checking h2 Queen B
- attacking the f2 pawn king g2
defending the pawn now black will really
have to you know really play the
absolute best most to prevent the
promotion of this point a very
interesting move it's hard to say they
didn't interview across a normal Madero
after the game because they played over
six hours so you know they didn't want
to bother them with with explaining this
entire position but definitely an
interesting idea
Bishop to e7 here night we have Queen to
f1 like we've said Knight to d5 now
across an exchanges captures captures
and now we have a queen to c1 we have f6
and now comes Queen to c2 you cannot
trick trick mummy they are up here by
playing something like c6 because after
captures c7 the promotion square is
guarded by the night and nice to e7 and
now after we bring the Queen captures
you get captures with check King h7
Queen to f5 check now you are attacking
the h5 pawn but black can defend it with
h6 so after all is said and done black
would actually enjoy an extra pawn here
so after f6 we have Queen to c2
attacking the g6 Knight e4 blocking we
have King to f1 and now King to f7 Queen
to a4 we have Quinta d3 check King moves
back and now King back to g8 Queen to a
to check a King moves back to h7 king h2
and now comes Queen to d1 Queen to a3
now preparing to push the pawn as the
Queen from a3 is guarding the bishop but
now comes Queen to d2 again not allowing
Causton to put the pawn because the f2
point would be under attack Queen III
offering a trade of Queens while
defending the pawn of course if you
capture and F captures and e3 is played
then of course black is lost
there's no no way to prevent the
promotion of this pawn so Queen to d5
again not going for the exchange Queen
to c1 we have King to g8 and knocking
back to g1 repeating the position
a few times as you know you have to play
something King to f7 Queen to a-1 King
to g8 Quinta c1 king to f7 and now Queen
to be won we have nine three seven and
now calls and exchanges captures
captures and here we have Queen to b6
again hoping to pull the C pawn my media
doesn't allow it Queen d1 check King
moves and out comes Queen to d4 again
threatening to capture on f2 Queen - b7
check King e6 and down comes Queen to c6
check King g7 and now King to g2 again
cousin has to protect the pawn and here
Mamedov only has one good move to
continue playing this position and that
is e three and he plays it so what's the
idea behind the e3 the idea is if cousin
captures this for example F captures on
e3 you get the Queen captures on e3 and
after Queen to d6 check King would move
and after c6 trying to promote the pawn
there is actually no way to do it as
Queen e2 will be a draw by repetition of
moves after a king h3 you can check here
King moves check King moves checking
Muscat check King moves Queen g4 check
and of course you can simply continue
checking wherever the White King goes so
after a 3-course and tries to Queen b7
check we have king to e6 and now Queen
to see it check we have King to d5 and
now comes F captures on e3 and here mama
deriv doesn't capture the pawn
rather he plays Queen to g3 Queen to g4
offering afraid of Queens if you capture
on e3 immediately it's still gonna be a
draw but you know you don't want to risk
it you've been playing for six hours you
don't want something like Queen b7 check
King characters and Queen h7 check
happening where you would lose your
queen and the game but of course that's
very unlikely to happen in in a game
between two 2800 queen g4 offering a
queen trade and while it while it's okay
to capture the Queen Queen captures aged
captures and after King captures here it
was it would still be a draw but you
know better better not risk it like we
said they've been playing for six hours
so after half captures on e3 queen g4
was played across and played Queen to d8
check
stating that there is no way for him to
actually keep the extra pawn and it was
in this
that they agreed to a draw whatever you
play after keen captures its King f2 is
sufficient to hold the draw not allowing
Queen to eat too but even that or you
can start checking I mean the king is
wide open you can just check him for as
long as you like and well you know it is
an open position with a lot of checks
possible both of them are very tired and
the day you know none of them will
actually gain anything they are both
leaders in the tournament so far and you
can only mess up here so yeah after
Queen to d8 check and they agreed to a
draw and a wonderful wonderful rule
Lopes game between these two 2,800
players and so I don't forget these are
the standings after round five of the
2018 bill chess tournament Magnus
Carlsen still in first with you know he
he does have a better performance so far
so three and a half Momiji are also
three and a half then Peter Svidler with
three out of five then comes Navarro
David with two and a half out of five so
he's on 50% Maxine Varela Grove with two
out of five and Nico gurgi is with only
half a point out of five but those half
that half a point came from drawing a
game against Magnus Carlsen so yeah
that's it it's very interesting tomorrow
is also around 6:00 and only then will
the players have a rest day and they
announce something like they will go on
a boat trip so as you've seen in the
candidates tournament my media really
likes both trips so I would like to
thank the missing video John Abraham and
Anthony video Panda for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
tomorrow morning definitely wood with
another Bobby Fischer video from the
series and then in the afternoon of
course covering round six of the bill
chess festival thank you all and I'll
see you soon